i am in real trouble  just because of my work please uk  government  do not punish my family  do not leave them behind  because that's gonna  cause lots of life  if anything happened to my family  you know  how come i live that life after  you know  it's really hard it's really hard i'm  struggling i'm still struggling  you know  i'm kind of losing hope  uh  it's  i haven't seen my family seven and a  half year ago since 2014. can you  imagine that  three days ago  because  they say son because of your work you  know the the neighboring the neighbors  knows if they come  to  they take my two brothers that's what  they're gonna do  this is just the only beginning that  taliban is doing right now is just only  a show  i'm sorry like i have pains it should  come out  so it's we are just  kind of giving each other hope at the  moment try to survive  the only thing that is left is a hope  i hope there will be changes i hope they  will evacuate my family  you